one of the questions that I get all the
time it's Justine what cameras do you
use what gear are you using what
accessories are you using with your
cameras today I'm gonna go through some
of those setups and show you what I
think the best vlogging setups are I've
been using Sony for the past several
years so these are all setups that are
geared toward Sony cameras but a lot of
the accessories they can be used with
any cameras so this is kind of just a
starting points of inspiration to get
you guys started I'm making this video
also an author of vlog university it's a
conference that I'm having in Los
Angeles today we're announcing that you
can bring a friend for free to vlog
University I'm so excited about this
because one of the most important parts
about creating content is involving your
friends and your family and for me that
is such an important part a lot of you
guys have so much passion for content
creation and I know that some of your
friends and family might not quite
understand this whole world that you're
diving into so if you have a ticket
already check your email you'll be
receiving all of the information there
shortly and you haven't bought a ticket
yet get your ticket first and then we'll
be sending you a follow-up email so
you'll be able to bring your friend for
a discount on tickets use vlog 25 and
check out vlog University comm for all
of the info so now let's get into the
vlogging setups setup number one
this is Saudis are at zero mark two this
camera is very interesting because it's
pretty powerful it has a one-inch sensor
that's the same sensor that's in the
rx100 series but this little guy is so
small and so compact that if you're out
filming with this no one is even gonna
question you they might laugh at you
because this is so silly
Tyler is over there he's like just see
no one's gonna vlog with that and I was
like well I think they will because look
at this did it attack Tyler do you see
yourself I don't see myself okay okay he
didn't like the tripod the camera he was
in too it's just this this was actually
an accident I thought that I ordered a
tripod that was this size and when this
showed up I was like this is
unbelievable it's so freaking cute I
myself personally would vlog with this
little tiny thing I'm gonna look at it
it's so small and compact if you're
looking for Portability and look no
further for Tyler's sake I'm gonna
switch it out to her Perry we're gonna
be using this rode microphone this is
the microphone that I feel like
has been in every youtubers vlogger
starter kit ever since the beginning of
time I've been using this one for a
while but it's not my favorite just
because it is kind of large and you also
do have to always have a 9-volt battery
on hand because the battery will die
they'll say because I always forget to
turn it off and then I forget to turn it
on when I'm recording but this is the
standard-issue vlogger mic it works so
let's mount this little guy in here look
at this I love this little flip up
screen like it's so cute
here's a little audio input I just
wrapped this cord just around like that
this is a fixed focus camera so when you
hit record whatever is in focus at the
beginning of recording that's what stays
in focus but once you kind of get used
to shooting in that style it's pretty
great this is an option I think if you
are a travel vlogger or somebody who
doesn't want to carry a lot of gear this
little camera can get the job done you
can also power it so if you do need to
have it powered on the go you can charge
it through USB it's small its light its
compact I want to put the little legs
back on just to see what it looks like
with this look at this it's even smaller
and lighter and more compact it's
perfect it's honestly like it's
Christmas it's great hey guys it's
Justine today I'm vlogging on the most
interesting regula ever see rxz row test
with no microphone I really want to give
you guys a sense of what this sounds
like with and without a microphone to
let you be able to judge if you need one
or not this one I know already sounds
pretty good because I've used this
camera a lot now let's see what it
sounds like with the microphone we've
now got the rode mic attached to this I
mean this looks so silly like I'm just
looking at it this camera is so small
one of the things I do want to stress as
these are just suggestions you can swap
this mic out for something different
something smaller something lighter
something a completely different brand
these are all suggestions of places to
start vlogging rig number 2 this is the
new rx 100 mark 5 it came out well a few
months ago so it's not that new but the
introduction of an audio input jack
right here has changed the game as far
as what you can do with this this tiny
little SAR monic microphone is something
that really got
introduced to their line of microphones
I love this because if I'm filming
myself I can get my audio in the front
and then if I flip it around but I still
want my voice to come through I can just
flip this and be able to get my audio
and continue shooting the rx100 series
has been a camera that I've been using
for a really long time I've done many
reviews on these cameras in the past if
you do want to check those out we'll put
all the links in the description but
this is it it shoots 4k the internal
audio is pretty good so you don't really
need to have a microphone but once you
have a microphone it's really difficult
to go back because you realize how much
of a difference this makes this tripod
is a Benro tripod and this one's nice
because you can tighten and loosen and
kind of move around your camera so that
allows you to have a lot more
flexibility especially if you have a
heavier camera the tripod that I also
use pretty often is one of these little
guys it's a Manfrotto
so you push this button in that allows
you to move the top but if you do have a
have your camera I would recommend the
Ben girl I have traveled around the
world with this camera it has captured
so many things if you do end up getting
one of these I would recommend getting a
screen protector this is a touch screen
so you obviously don't want that damage
when you're traveling or vlogging so it
protective screen will help you reduce
any shattering of the back screen in any
of the adventures that you might be
taking this thing on if you want to take
this room to the next level I am a huge
fan of small rig they have so many great
cages for cameras this just lets you
elevate this very small camera into
having like a nice little grip you have
a cold shoe right here so you can attach
audio you can attach a light let me show
you this super cute little light that I
found at CES this year this is by light
raw can you believe this look how cute
oh it's great about these cages you guys
can see there's all of these little
holes you can add so many different
accessories that it's pretty
overwhelming the amount of
is that you can build it out of just
these little cages you can continue to
use this little microphone but I also
found these recently these are also by
Tsar Manik this is a wireless solution
by Tsar Manik and what's really great
about this is there's a receiver and
there's also two transmitters so if my
sister and I are out making videos we
both gonna have a microphone on and you
only need one receiver so this gauge
also has a cool shoot on the side so you
can mount the light over here but right
now I'm going to mount this microphone
here for the sake of this video and then
you just plug this in the wire can run
right behind you could also attach a lot
to this but this itself acts as a
microphone yeah this might look a little
bit silly but you don't need anything
else you can just use this or if you're
doing like an interview or something you
can hold the microphones like this but
these both connect to one transmitter
these do record audio on the same track
and I think that's a small price to pay
for the ease of use of these things and
you basically just turn it on and go
let's finish this rig up there we have
it
I'm ready to vlog this is probably one
of my favorite ribs that I've ever built
it's small its compact its versatile you
have light you have audio in you
basically have everything that you need
right here so this is the Sony rx100
Mark 5 I have a little light on and it
is so bright I don't actually need this
light on at all I have a little tiny
harmonic microphone plugged into it and
this is kind of just giving me a little
bit more of a directional sound there
are a ton of sirens everywhere
Tyler was going to have you say
something and I realized that I was out
of coffee filters this this way now
since I was out of coffee filters I
didn't know what to do so I grabbed a
bunch of paper towels okay so - Tyler's
telling his story I just decided that I
think that this would sound much better
if Tyler had a loved one so that I could
really hear what he's saying cuz this is
super riveting content ok Tyler tell me
about your story oh where was I
so yeah I was using paper towels to try
to make a coffee filter and I thought I
did a good job and when I put the coffee
in and I poured the hot water over the
coffee
it went all into my coffee maker and
ruined it and then I went back to bed
testing out the wireless harmonic with
this lot of microphones I'm gonna set
you guys down and we're gonna see what
it sounds like we're gonna go back here
look at the plants enjoy the view my
trees are so dirty like I don't
understand like this is so gross there's
like cobwebs and dirt I mean I realize
these are trees that are outside ok so
far which setups you guys like and last
but not least this is the camera that
I've been using ever since this one came
out this is the a7 3 this is a big boy
this is a full-frame camera we have a G
master lens on it right now we have a 24
to 70 but if you are vlogging I would
recommend a 16 to 35 although this 24
70 is probably one of my favorite lenses
that Sony has made we use this for
almost all of the b-roll shots this is
also one of the newer microphones that
Sony came out with it's not it a little
more expensive but the sound quality is
amazing what I love so much is there's
some no cables involved it sends the
signal directly from the microphone to
the camera you don't have to power it
because it's also powered by the camera
I definitely recommend it since this is
a bigger camera we've got one of the
bigger Joby tripods there's so many Joby
options I don't typically use these that
often but if you are vlogging these are
so nice to hold because you can actually
get a grip with a bigger camera and a
bigger lens like this sometimes this is
not that stable and I have this way too
close to a swimming pool once my camera
Justine did you just drop your camera in
there you have to go get them oh my
heart hurts that camera is so expensive
so since this is the camera that I use
most often we kind of use a little more
advanced audio system this definitely
will make your vlogging rig a lot
heavier but having these XLR inputs is
great because you can use different
microphones you can swap out and have a
shotgun mic usually for a wireless audio
I will use these these are the
Sennheiser AVX I'm using it for the past
couple of years and this is great
especially if we have two people because
I can record each track separately being
able to have two people on two separate
audio tracks I think is really important
just in case one person's audio isn't
working properly you always have the
backup of the other person this is the
a7 3 with the 24 to 70 I did recommend
using the 16 to 35 it's a lot lighter
and you'll get a more wider field of
view so I pressed down slightly on the
shutter button to get a focus and you
just kind of help you just hope for the
best
because right now I have no idea it
might be in focus it might not be this
thing is also extremely heavy here it is
baby tiny little teeny tiny mic did you
think that this was gonna be lighter
just seen did you think it was gonna be
lighter cuz it's not I would say this is
one of the higher-end vlogging cameras
and there is something that is kind of
right in between the rx100 Mark v and
this guy
so there's a bunch of smaller Sony
options this is the a 6400 it's not a
full-frame camera so you're not gonna be
getting as great picture quality as you
are with this one this little lens right
here is very inexpensive this is a 10 to
18 lens still one of my favorite lenses
it's not gonna be as good quality as
some of the G master ones sometimes
having a small portable camera is more
important to be able to just get the
shot if you are looking for a more
inexpensive option this is definitely
the way to go this is the 6400 and
what's great about this is it does have
a flip up screen this also has a hot
shoe right here but I got one of these
little small rig extenders which allowed
me to take the hot shoe turned it into a
cold shoe so that I can move the
microphone right over to here so this is
the Sony a 64 hundred there's a bunch of
different models of this similar type of
Micro Four Thirds sensor but this one
does have an audio input which is
amazing because I am obsessed with
making sure that I have good audio this
is the rode microphone this is a very
similar setup that I used when I was
traveling around Germany and Rome in
Italy a few years ago we had the a 6400
and if it was windy I was using this
type of microphone but since it was a
6400 we didn't have the flip up screen
so I mostly was using this microphone
because you don't need any cables or any
wires like I said this just connects
right to the hotshoe I didn't show you
guys this before but hold on a second
so look at this little guy I call this
the microphones thong the little flower
just of these and this is great because
you do have the left and the right audio
but if you're doing an interview or
something you can just pop these little
guys right out just like that and you
can get audio from each person so this
is what it sounds like without a
microphone again a 6400 no microphone
this is all onboard that's what it
sounds like you do to be careful though
because if you are zooming in and out
you guys hear that you're vlogging yeah
do you're zooming while you're not
talking and that's it here's a few of
the vlogging rigs that I've been
enjoying and loving if you guys have any
suggestions on things that you're using
please leave them in the comments below
and feel free to tweet them to me on
Twitter if you happen to be in Los
Angeles on January 31st through February
1st please come to vlog university if
you've ever had any interest in creating
content it's gonna be so much fun check
out vlog University comm for all of the
details
sure to use this discount code at
checkout I hope to see you guys there
[Music]